PART OF THE 2020 EQUATION.
THE OTHER IS WHAT THE NEWS CYCLE
WILL BRING.
THE NEXT GUEST SAYS THE MEDIA
WILL BE REFLEXIVELY ANTI-TRUMP
BUT THEY WON'T HAVE THE RELIABLE
MUELLER STORY TO OBSESS OVER,
THEY MIGHT HAVE TO CONFRONT SOME
HARD TRUTHS ABOUT WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED WITH THESE NEW
INVESTIGATIONS COMING TO
FRUITION.
VICTOR, GOOD TO HAVE YOU BACK.
YOU HAVE SOME BIG PREDICTIONS
ABOUT WHAT STORIES WILL DOMINATE
HEAD OF THE 2020 ELECTION, TELL
US.
>> I THINK THE MUELLER STORY IS
THROUGH AND IT'S A BOOMERANG
EFFECT, NOW WE ARE GOING TO SEE
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE INSTRUMENTAL
IN SUBVERTING THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
TRANSITION AND THE PRESIDENCY
ARE GOING TO BE CALLED TO
ACCOUNT.
WE HEARD THIS WALLS ARE CLOSE
AGAIN BUT IT'S GOING TO ACT IN
REVERSE.
COMEY, BRENNAN, McCABE,
BRUCE OHR AND HIS WIFE ARE
FACING CRIMINAL REFERRALS AND
THIS IS GOING TO BE A SLOW,
DRAWN-OUT PROCESS ALL THE WAY TO
THE 2020 ELECTION.
YOU MENTION THE GOOD ECONOMY,
IT'S SOMETHING TRUMP NEEDS TO
FOCUS MORE ON.
THE TWO AREAS WHERE HE MIGHT BE
VULNERABLE, WE'VE HAD A MILLION
ILLEGAL ALIENS COMING IN HALF A
YEAR, THERE IS NO ALTERNATIVE
FROM THE DEMOCRATS.
HE WANTED TO SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT AND HE DID TO STOP
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, HE PUT A
TARIFF AND HE WOULD'VE ON
MEXICO.
HE'S DOING ALL HE CAN, THAT'S
NOT GOING TO BE AN ISSUE FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, THEY CAN'T SAY "WE
WOULD STOP IMMIGRATION" BECAUSE
THEY WANT MORE OF IT.
AND WE HAVE A BIG ANNUAL DEFICIT
AND TRUMP MIGHT BE VULNERABLE
THERE BUT THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
HAVE A REPUTATION FOR FISCAL
SOBRIETY.
AREAS WERE TRUMP MIGHT BE
VULNERABLE.
>> Laura: THEY ARE GOING TO BE
WORSE ON THE BORDER, THEY'RE
GOING TO BE WORSE ON SPENDING,
THEY ARE GOING TO BE WORSE ON
ALL OF THE THINGS THAT HE MIGHT
BE VULNERABLE ON IN ANOTHER TYPE
OF ELECTION.
I HAVE TO GET TO THIS, ABC
RELEASED PART OF A GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND IT'S GETTING WALL-TO-WALL
COVERAGE ON THE NETWORKS, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> IF FOREIGNERS, RUSSIA, CHINA,
OFFERS YOU INFORMATION ON
OPPONENTS, SHOULD THEY ACCEPT IT
OR CALL THE FBI?
>> YOU DO BOTH, I THINK YOU
MIGHT WANT TO LISTEN, THERE'S
NOTHING WRONG WITH LISTENING.
IF SOMEBODY CALLED FOR MY
COUNTRY, NORWAY, WE HAVE
INFORMATION ON YOUR OPPONENT --
I THINK I WOULD WANT TO HEAR IT.
>> YOU WANT THAT KIND OF
INTERFERENCE ON OUR ELECTIONS?
>> IT'S NOT INTERFERENCE, I
THINK I WOULD TAKE IT.
IF I THOUGHT THERE WAS SOMETHING
WRONG I WOULD GO TO THE FBI.
>> Laura: SETTING ASIDE THE
QUESTION OF WHY YOU WOULD HAVE
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS STANDING
OVER THE PRESIDENT IN THE
OVAL OFFICE, I DON'T KNOW WHO
APPROVED THAT.
WHAT ABOUT THIS NOTION OF
ACCEPTING FOREIGN INTEL ON AN
OPPONENT?
WHY HE WAS PUT IN THAT SITUATION
WAS BEYOND ME.
>> YOU SHOULDN'T EVER TALK TO
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS AND TWO,
ANY QUESTION ABOUT FOREIGN
INTELLIGENCE, THAT SHOULD BE THE
END OF THE CONVERSATION BECAUSE
IT CAN BE MANIPULATED AND
DISTORTED.
WHAT HE WAS PROBABLY SAYING, I
THINK HE INTENDED TO SAY
SOMETHING LIKE ADAM SCHIFF WHO
GOT FOOLED BY THOSE RUSSIAN
COMEDIANS WHO HAD DIRT AND HE
WAS EXCITED, ALL OF THESE
POLITICIANS HEAR THIS KINDS OF
STUFF FROM ALL SOURCES, I THINK
THE CARDINAL RULE IS YOU DON'T
DISCUSS THAT.
>> Laura: HE SEEMS LIKE HE'S
PLAYING WITH GEORGE
STEPHANOPOULOS A LITTLE BIT.
HE SAID RUSSIA, GET HILLARY'S